[Musique]
et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous ou
agnès callamard bonjour
merci beaucoup de nous rejoindre sur
l'antenne de france 24 vous êtes la
secrétaire générale d'amnesty
international depuis johannesbourg en
afrique du sud vous nous direz dans un
instant pourquoi vous êtes là bas
aujourd'hui alors que vous publiez votre
bilan annuel de la situation des droits
humains à travers le monde je voudrais
commencer si vous le voulez bien est ce
qu'à la marque par parler de l'ukraine
près de cinq semaines d'invasion et de
guerre des crimes de guerre agnès
callamard sont-ils commis en ce moment
et bubu début l'invasion russe en
ukraine so lu ment absolument amnesty
international a déjà
documenté des deux attaques contre des
civils des infrastructures civiles qui
constitue sans aucun doute des crimes de
guerre nous avons aussi documenté le
fait que les populations ne puisse pas
échapper aux sièges dont celui de mario
coll nous savons aussi de notre histoire
du travail que nous avons fait en syrie
ou en grozny les pratiques des autorités
russes des militaires russes donc il ne
fait aucun doute qu'à l'heure actuelle
ce pays est en feu et que ces gens
subissent des violations massives de
leurs droits à la fois des droits des
trois humains et des droits humanitaires
ces crimes de guerre agnès callamard
sont ils selon vous commises sur ordre
direct de moscou où sont ils le fait de
soldats ici et là sur un terrain de
guerre que l'on imagine compliqué
écoutez c'est une question c'est une
question trop compliquée il faudra qu'il
y ait enquête il faut absolument que la
cour pénale internationale
enquête sur ces crimes de guerre afin
d'enquêter sur la responsabilité des
plus hauts placés ce qui est plutôt un
clair c'est qu'il y à une pratique à
l'échelle de
cette guerre qui consiste à
délibérément s'attaquer aux civils et
aux infrastructures civiles ce ne sont
pas des accidents ce ne sont pas des
attaques indiscriminées il semblerait
bien que nous parlons d'un stack
délibéré donc dans ce cas là il s'agit
de quelque chose qui est quand même de
planifier qui fait partie d'un plan les
je dirai juste les occidentaux agnès
callamard n'ont pas établi de lignes
rouges un seuil au-delà duquel leur
engagement pourrait changer de forme ans
en ukraine comment est ce que vous le
comprenez
écouter les lignes rouges sont sans
tracé par par le droit international les
lignes rouges sont très claires la
russie les a dépassé depuis très
longtemps et bien sûr il n'était pas
sans d'ukraine ils les ont dépassés en
syrie et le ce point là d'ailleurs me
permets de vous deux vous de partager
l'inde est l'une des conclusions de
notre rapport annuel qui est que depuis
en 2021 nous avons vu un dd des
institutions multilatérales complètement
sens ans sans possibilité de travailler
il ne s'agit plus maintenant en fait
donc conseil de la sécurité mais bien
d'un conseil de la sécurité auxquels
auquel nous nous avons donné tous nos
tous nos espoirs donc les lignes rouges
sont dépassées mais depuis depuis
malheureusement des années madame
dernière question en as calamars sur la
situation en ukraine l'europe connaît
l'exil de civils le plus important
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
comment jugez-vous la capacité ou
l'incapacité des européens à y faire
face à commencer par celle du premier
pays concerné la pologne
écoutez à l'heure actuelle la pologne et
pays limitrophes ont géré cette crise
avec beaucoup de générosité il faut que
cette générosité se joue à l'échelle
européenne est en effet à l'échelle
internationale il faut que les états ne
sont pas limitrophes participent
activement à 1,7 à cette politique des
réfugiés mais j'irai plus loin ce que
cette politique démontre c'est que nous
en avons la capacité
nous en avons les moyens il ne faut pas
faire de discrimination
à l'heure où la pologne est si généreuse
à l'égard des réfugiés qui arrivent du
trail il y à des réfugiés qui sont
coincés entre la frontière des lots
russe et polonaise et qui sont en train
de mourir ces réfugiés là aussi il faut
les accueillir donc ne il faut que nous
soyons en accord avec les valeurs pour
lesquelles nous nous battons à l'heure
actuelle contre la russie ces valeurs là
il faut qu'on les applique à l'échelle
internationale pas seulement à une
population ce sont des valeurs
humanitaires ce sont des valeurs des
droits humains ce sont des valeurs
humanistes il faut qu'on les applique à
l'ensemble des réfugiés à l'image de la
situation dans l'est de l'europe vous
décrivez agnès callamard dans ce rapport
ce bilan annuel des droits humains un
état assez sombre du monde où les
conflits sont légions syrie yémen
ethiopie on va y revenir un monde qui
devait être aussi celui du monde à
d'après poste qu'ovide vous écrivez dans
ce rapport qu'il n'en est absolument
rien
c'est un monde de la trahison
2021 soyons clairs c'est la trahison
c'est la trahison des dirigeants à à
l'égard des populations
ils nous ont annoncé au début de l'année
nous allons reconstruire en mieux en
bien ils ont fait exactement l'inversé
nous avons pour des raisons de profit
pour des raisons de économique nous
avons
me la moiti là la grande partie du monde
incapable d'avoir accès à un accès ce
qui signifie non seulement des millions
de morts à travers le monde mais ça
signifie aussi que l'économie globale
nam a dû redémarrer et pendant que tout
cela se passait les grandes compagnies
pharmaceutiques
elle a cumulé accumulé vous le savez que
à l'heure actuelle on estime que les
deux plus grands riders et modern art
ont accumulé 54 20 milliards de dollars
d'intérêt alors que l'économie mondiale
est sur les genoux cette économie
mondiale est à genoux il y a maintenant
la guerre en russie qui va apporter des
guerres de la fin ddd la guerre par
aidés des problèmes par rapport à la
gaz au fuel et cetera c'est une trahison
auxquels nous faisons face une trahison
et si vous êtes aujourd'hui précisément
à johannesbourg en afrique du sud c'est
bien parce que le continent africain et
dites vous le symbole de cette inégalité
dans l'accès aux traitements j'allais
dire sur le co vide mais malheureusement
pas que à propos du candidat bien sûr à
4 actions locaux les pays africains ont
reçu moins de 8% de 20 -2 8% de la
population africaine a été vaccinée à
l'heure actuelle
c'est bien sûr des morts dont on parle
ici qui aurait pu être évitée mais c'est
aussi le fait par exemple que loin là je
suis en afrique du sud
près de huit cent mille enfants ne sont
pas retourner à l'école l'année dernière
huit cent mille enfants c'est toute une
génération qui a été perdu pourquoi pour
des intérêts économiques d'une petite
minorité le l'incapacité de gérer
globalement le shérif globalement la
crise du coc vide ça veut dire que nous
avons des économies africaines qui sont
à genoux et qui maintenant font face à
cette guerre en ukraine ils sont
dépendants certaines régions comme
l'afrique de l'est dépendante jusqu'à
90% de la russie et de l'ukraine pour
semblez vous imaginez dans quel état ces
économies vont se retrouver tout ça
c'est le produit de 2021 le produit de
la trahison des dirigeants avec les
intérêts corporatistes d'une toute
petite minorité
l'année 2000 21 al ahmar a été marquée
par le retour au pouvoir des talibans en
afghanistan il ya quelques jours ils ont
interdit l'accès au secondaire aux
filles en dépit de leurs promesses est
ce le signe selon vous que ces talibans
sont les mêmes qu'il ya vingt ans
ça ne fait pour amnesty international il
n'y a aucun doute que les talibans sont
les même s'ils ont fait quelques petits
encarts alors à leur idéologie
c'était pour des raisons tout à fait
pragmatique et de realpolitik
ce que nous observons depuis qu'ils sont
au pouvoir c'est donc le le fait que les
jeunes femmes n'ont pas accès à
l'éducation le fait que les minorités
sont ciblés le fait que les plus de deux
cents 200 médias afghanes ont disparu
après la prise de leur pouvoir mais
permettez moi d'ajouter que
l'afghanistan c'est aussi d'un certain
côté le ce qui annonce un l'ukraine
l'aghanistan c'est la démonstration
encore une fois de l'incapacité de la
communauté internationale à gérer à
gérer des crises à gérer son départ
c'est ça a commencé avec la birmanie ça
a continué avec l'aghanistan on le
revoit avec le conflit en israël et et
le conflit en est sûr qu'ils nous
parlons ici d'un système international
sur les genoux et d'un conseil de la
sécurité qui est vraiment devenu un
conseil de l'insécurité
l'afghanistan à agnès callamard c'est
aussi de l'autre côté de la médaille
quelque part un an formidable et quel
exemple de résistance d'une partie de la
société civile on a vu cette jeune femme
ces jeunes filles manifesté pour
réclamer le droit d'aller à l'école face
au recul de la liberté d'expression le
courage de dire non et quel courage on
l'a vu aussi en russie récemment ces
quelques russes qui qui en dépit des
risques manifestes pour dire non à la
guerre ça aussi vous le mettez dans
votre rapport cette force là je ne
voudrais pas que que les gens qui nous
écoutent pense que nous n'avons qu'un
espoir pas du tout nous avons trouvé que
dans 80 pays
sur lesquels nous travaillons
les gens se sont soulevés les gens ne
sont pas restés silencieux ils se sont
allés au prix alors prix de leur vie
même
manifesté pour qu'on ne leur volent par
leurs droits leur révolution comme comme
au soudan par exemple il y a à travers
la société civile du monde une demande
de justice que l'on retrouve partout il
ya aussi il ya aussi des des exemples
très claire de deux systèmes judiciaires
qui tiennent le coup et qui permettent
de se battre donc il ya encore des
institutions formelles qui sont alliés à
la protection des droits
l'année dernière il ya eu des cas de
justice remarquable où les grandes
compagnies par exemple les médias
sociaux ont été ont été trouvés
coupables de crimes qu'elles avaient
commis on a vu aussi l'utilisation de la
juridiction universelle pour juger des
criminels de guerre qui ne pouvait pas
être jugé dans l'eure dans leur pays il
y a il y a de l'espoir il y a une vision
d'un autre monde d'une autre façon de
faire les choses deux dernières
questions pour se projeter un peu dans
l'avenir si vous le voulez bien agnès
callamard d'abord quelques mots de la
présidentielle en france si vous voulez
bien c'est dans douze jours ici qu'est
ce que l'état du débat public notamment
sur les questions d'identité de
migration de droit d'asile ici en france
on vous inspire en quelques mots
elle m'inspire un grand dégoût voilà je
pense qu'il n'y a pas d'autres termes
nous nous battons à l'heure actuelle
pour des valeurs contre la russie nous
nous battons pour un monde autre que
celui que la russie souhaite amener en
faisant cet acte d'agression contre des
règles internationales contre le droit
international
il s'agit pour nous tous à travers le
monde de conserver ses valeurs pas de
les dispenser
selon nos nos nos désirs ses valeurs
s'applique à l'échelle universelle
donc quand on commence à faire des
distinguo entre populations entre jean
et cetera je me dis on n'a jamais gagné
on n'a jamais gagné cette guerre donc
voilà un grand dégoût merci pour cette
cette franchise et puis un dernier mot
sur la coupe du monde au qatar qui se
tiendra dans huit mois la grande fête du
football se jouera ce jour a dit vous au
détriment des droits humains je sais
qu'il ya une manifestation d'amnesty en
ce sens le week-end dernier dans le sud
de la france
écoutez 1 le sport ne doit pas devenir
le moyens par lesquels les gouvernements
se refont une santé
publique le sport ne doit pas être le
l'endroit le ou les droits les droits
humains sans violer malheureusement au
qatar le travail d'amnesty a démontré
que les travailleurs surtout les
travailleurs immigrés ont été très mal
traités par par les par la part le par
le système si vous voulez cela fait
appel non seulement aussi aux compagnies
de construction qui sont impliquées dans
la construction de stades mais ça fait
aussi ça implique aussi le lion
internationale du football tout c'est
tous ces clubs de sport qui sent prêt au
nom de nouveau de l'argent au nom de
l'argent à flouer les droits des gens
qui travaillent pour eux finalement donc
en effet il faut il faut célébrer le
sport c'est formidable le sport mais il
faut le célébrer au nom de notre unique
de notre universalité commune au nom de
nos droits communs il faut que le sport
devienne le moyen d'expression de sept
de ses valeurs il ne faut pas il ne faut
surtout pas que l'on viole les droits
des gens pour que que pour que certaines
personnes puissent avoir une ou deux
heures de plaisir c'est impensable merci
beaucoup merci agnès callamard d'avoir
répondu à nos questions à deux puis à
johannesbourg en afrique du sud je
renvoie ceux qui nous regardent à la
lecture de votre bilan annuel sur la
situation des droits humains celui
d'amnesty on voit l'antenne qui est
sorti depuis quelques heures merci
encore et bonne journée à vous qu'on se
retrouve juste après la pause pour la
suite de paris direct avec